welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to see yesterday has just dropped
on Netflix and the new time-travel film
has a hell of a lot to impart from it
the movie is being touted as Back to the
Future meets the hey you give and
throughout there's a lot of symbolism
and metaphor that really elevates the
film above your typical time trouble
affair throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie as well as what
I took from its ending this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
see yesterday yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give the huge thank you for
click in this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of see you yesterday the film
follows best friends CJ and Sebastian
who are working on a machine that has
the ability to send it to back into the
past whilst the movie initially has a
rather playful tone to it things quickly
change for the pair when CJ's brother
Calvin is tragically killed by a
policeman after a case of mistaken
identity instantly this grounds the
movie and going into this film knowing
very little it wasn't a turn that I was
expecting that you all decide that they
have to go back to stop the tragedy but
the real tragedy is that they shouldn't
have to in the first place the movie
takes a firm stance that police
brutality and the deaths of innocent
lives and stop similar to what we see
play out are becoming too much of a
problem to be ignored we have made it
far too easy to kill one another and
this is a pretty firm statement that we
need to reassess how we as people treat
one another whilst police get a pretty
bad rap it also paints the opposite side
of the argument with the gangs in the
film having as much blood on their hands
as the apparent oppress
though the film is laced with social
commentary while I love about see you
yesterday is that it doesn't beat you
over the head with it
the movie paints both sides of the
argument in all of its issues there's an
amazing scene to do with feminism and
men standing up for women in an overly
protective way with both the characters
putting their pros and cons across which
makes the movie easy to appreciate and
lets you know that this piece is here to
make you think rather than to tell you
what you should this too is reflected in
CJ who's an extremely complex character
and she holds a lot of guilt over her
aggressiveness and has to learn
throughout the film that who
hotheadedness gets her in more trouble
than it doesn't Michael J Fox who plays
CJ's teacher in an amazing cameo I've
used probably the biggest point of the
film with the fact that time-travel
ethically and philosophic repose is one
of the biggest conundrums ever as this
power would mean that the possessor
would have to decide what to change and
well what not to during the movie CJ
soon realizes that their actions
inadvertently cause more problems with
Sebastian being killed in the past and
though she saves her brother because of
it it's at a cost
this really laces the movie with
complexity and shows that sometimes
there is no right answer
anyway CJ discovers that she must tune
her time travel device frequency to the
previous jump and this allows her to go
back without Sebastian knowing and from
here divert to her brother to stop him
ever crossing paths with the police
however things aren't that simple and
watching the police arrive once more is
an extremely tense moment the had me
with my hands over my face wondering
what could happen in the end Calvin
sacrifices himself to avert the death of
Sebastian once more and this is really a
heartbreaking moment that showcases the
struggle that people have to go through
in these kind of situations it's a
damned if you do and damned if you don't
message that cements that as long as we
don't learn from these tragedies they
will forever continue to haunt us these
over-the-top stops and over
aggressiveness with the whole guilty
until proven innocent mind state that
the police take towards black youths
will forever cause the past to repeat
itself and we will continue to watch
more teenagers faces splashed across the
news now the main thing that I took from
its ending is that we cannot change the
past no matter how much we try instead
we must learn from our
and go forward with this new knowledge
in order to improve our future we can
never get back those that have been lost
but instead in their memory we have to
go forward with one another and stand up
for each other's rights the final scene
involves CJ going back once more to
attempt to stop it again though we don't
get confirmation that she succeeds
whilst it is a nihilistic viewpoint I
personally don't believe that she does
and that once more she will be stuck
with more loss whether it's her brother
or another innocent bystander that is
the true message of see you yesterday
there will forever be those at the
wayside brought in two murders like this
because the police seem to only be
willing to draw guns instead of talking
things out in addition to this the last
shot of her running could be heard
sacrificing herself as she realizes she
is the only one who can stop the entire
event this would to destroy the time
machine and mean that the cycle has
ended with Calvin and Sebastian ending
up safe there's no clear answer but
there doesn't need to be either there's
no end in sight to the violence and
instead we must take from this movie
that we have to change the way we think
act and behave towards one another in
order to progress positively into the
future and now on to my review see
yesterday is a powerful movie that stuck
with me long after I finished watching
it the piece is arguably one of the best
Netflix originals that's been released
this year and it's difficult to really
find fault with it the acting is
realistic grounded and earnest and the
social subtext is laced throughout to
let you draw your own conclusions
meaning that the film will be accessible
to all this is already one of the
strongest time-travel stories I've seen
and the fact that it's so easily
applicable to modern day makes it
relatable from start to finish
see yesterday is the one to watch on
Netflix this weekend and I definitely
recommend that you cancel your plans to
sit down to take it all in this is
outstanding
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and what you took from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of this week's other big movie John wick
chapter 3 which would be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who
were mad into movies so if that's the
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]